we leave them a little longer no I
wouldn't oh oh god damn that hurt Oh
today we are going to be waffling play
waffling chick I don't even know what
waffling means so waffling is a stiglitz
new movement people are doing everything
Freddie they're not where people really
just waffling random please yeah so
people do this on YouTube where they
waffle random things I guess I get my
mind it will make more sense to blend it
so you get a batter like material like
in a blender that is the because if you
think about it you will you make a
waffle you put on liquid so you make
like a chick-fil-a flavored waffle so
first item is the classic chicken
sandwich let's pray so the kids are
quite literally just putting these into
the waffle like there's no
unceremoniously
oh okay did it only go that far I mean I
could like push it's almost like you can
hear the screams of the chicken this
looks great this looks like a huge
waffle fry on top of the chicken the
chick-fil-a sandwich you see the bottom
that looks great those pickles are burnt
okay this are not better than I thought
I was really confused about this I might
be eating my words about the blending it
Cheers
oh my god
this will be great because now the
pockets are in there I'm gonna put a
little syrup and just in each one this
is genius they should do this they said
make a waffle sandwich why are they not
notice this is literally chicken and
waffles little great honest I don't know
better than I thought I did not realize
that we could waffle things I love it 10
out of 10
why would I give it turns in this is
this is we're gonna eat it
seven
we have the spy feet deluxe sandwich I'm
a wimp when it comes to spy so I might
not eat all of this I think like the
spice part is the cheese I think it over
just check pepper - we're about to make
a bomb waffle girl cheese Oh II thought
he allocated that yeah we can just do oh
oh get all up in and there be ready for
D sizzling more cuz of the cheese as
she's sticking is she a waffle wow that
looks pretty good
I get why kids are doing this we might
have lost the bottom bun this is already
points off for the chic and deluxe ones
about apparently the bottom bun is
weaker I think it was already wet
because of the tomato and the lettuce
it's still sizzling in here if you're
gonna waffle it as it's minimal liquidy
items as possible off I think but that's
not the rules the rules are to waffle ad
is I was to dive right on in the cheese
is really good I like the melted miss of
the cheese but I like far as the other
stuff let's tomato that just makes it
really gross and the lettuce is really
gross yeah the lettuce when it's hot is
not good
I don't mind the hot tomato though
reminds me of a panini panini this is
just a panini so maybe this isn't like
an Internet train it's just like I'm
broke college student was like I poured
a machine but I can get a goddamn waffle
iron either so more than awesome I think
the other flavors heated up in here
really like a Sun special do you think
it spicy no you're right those are solid
eight and a half I'm gonna give it a 9
out of 10 because of the tomato and
Lenin situation if you take it off
before you put it into the waffle maker
I feel like that would have been perfect
oh yeah put it on genius genius
[Applause]
we're back with the chicken nuggets
they're nuggets are very small but
they're so cute they are more palpable
they're like popcorn yeah how could you
can look feel it - in each little nook
yeah yeah oh so I think it's too small
to really see the full effect of a
little waffle like imprint but you can
see lows but you can see a little bit
and it really just smushed it down yes
yes we forgot the sock which is arguably
my most favoritest item but honestly
fantastic I could drink this
chick-fil-a sauce is great cheers Cheers
nom nom was it good it's really good
yeah it did make it a little more like
tough mm-hmm you're biting it through
they make them more crispy for sure it
didn't do much for me like the other
ones I think the sandwich and the deluxe
sandwich were really elevated by the
waffle love like this was just something
like I could have just eaten this
chicken nugget like this it was extra
time for no reason
I'd say yeah I would say afford to
didn't make it worse but it didn't do
anything extra right
we are onto the chicken ship so it is a
long-form chicken nugget and that is
really massive they are they're always
you want to do one one one each I think
we all right yeah you really took her
idea that I was so the realist came yeah
all right you know awful
yeah put your back into it Imam again
still feel like blending these things
will make it better not gonna let that
go blending chicken
yes blends it with the chick-fil-a sauce
in the syrup to make a batter then put
it in here you have a chicken flavored
waffle and say watch the Internet's
gonna blow up with this no yes it is
going to be the next thing let's bring
out the chicken man hoarsely oak but I
do love that you can see the little
squares and yeah this is obviously done
this is the uncooked one the I kinda
like it crispy I love it she's a fork
and a knife are you I don't know why I
feel like I like this more than the
chicken nugget but something about it
makes me go I like this more maybe
because there's more chicken uh maybe
did the Nugget was so tiny that is
though like well at least this feels
like it'll be worth the wait a minute
you actually doing something to it six
maybe seven I had a little more oomph
than the just regular chicken there yet
didn't blow my socks off my socks are
still on
these are chick-fil-a's waffle fries
they're already lawful the irony is not
lost that we are waffling waffle fries
yeah I don't know what that means but
did you ever think why not well that's
why these waffle fries okay now they're
more brown do you have to pour do you
use the sauce do I will use a little
ketchup that's already get off ketchup
say it one more time
ketchup like you you were saying ketchup
ketchup am I still seeing it ketchup
ketchup Oh crunchy mm-hmm for me I think
these crispy fries really hit the spot
I'm gonna go to solid eight and you know
what I think what also might help if you
are at home waffling your Neil do these
last because that way it's getting all
the flavor from all the other items too
I think that's healthy
I think I would have to say eight as
well five chick-fil-a products one
waffle maker it's a good afternoon if I
had a waffle iron at home I would not
leave it's like like yeah I wouldn't go
out of my way to go do you know waffle
iron for this but if I have one at home
I'm okay yeah it was fun that's it's a
fun way to spend an afternoon with a
friend oh I wasn't talking about you
[Laughter]
[Music]